I have to ask that he probably get this
all the time yes where did you can't
really yes
yeah how did you it's when for us
Johnson who will be prime minister yes
please mr. pariah
yes prime minister in perpetuity boys
Johnson yeah exactly it's when he was
asked what does he like to do to relax
and he said that he paints model buses
and it was a very strange garbled
response and I just thought that it
would be quite funny to have somebody in
the next room feeding him the lines
because it seemed like he was expecting
somebody to give him the lines he didn't
know how to respond like a human being
yeah cuz boy Boris actually he looks
like that lot doesn't he he has this
habit of sort of looking over his
shoulder and then yeah like some
invisible person like he's waiting for
them to turn yeah yeah it's still Prime
Minister it's just amazing isn't it
anyway so yeah so there was that and
then I I thought it was really low
hanging fruit I thought I don't think
I'll do it really IMing and worrying
about doing it and then I thought well
I'll do it and see what happens and it
just went completely mad yeah well like
all the best ideas you want to think
it's too obvious isn't it oh yeah it was
yeah okay and so then so then this
afterthought has been quite popular yes
okay so I mean you know a Michael of
brief experience sometimes of having
like tweets go viral yes it is quite an
intense strange experiences now yeah and
you've gone kind of make you write yeah
has it been it's been okay it can be
very unpleasant no no it's it's you know
so far it's been absolutely amazing with
full of with virtually a hundred percent
of all positive Twitter reaction that it
was not sure there's many people that
could say that really yeah
I've not been trolled or abused in any
way and you and you cuz you how many
videos you with you have you done actor
because if mother why I'm about
seventeen yeah like things are evolving
the one you did yeah yeah yeah it's
amazing so you did this recent one where
at the end we're so that you just walked
out and stared at that you know I really
know if I said it's an all seriousness
it moves me did it yeah it really did
afterwards I was like wow yeah and I
feel like it's amazing to see the the
artform develop and so which obviously
Smith the question I mean where where do
you kind of
to carry on with it where do you go with
it I mean I to be honest I've got a
folder this just says Trump I've got
like 10 Trump yeah because I don't have
the time yes and yeah oh yeah the word
the room next door man yeah yeah it's
nice that's gonna that's gonna go in
your on your gravestone now yeah the
room next door man dies it'll be in my
[ __ ] room yeah exactly
no yes so it's it I'd really want to do
Trump and I want to do I want to do more
but I do want to evolve I don't want to
turn into the I didn't do it boy I want
to kind of you know build on it I guess
because we should say I mean you've got
a regular job right right you don't go
to work in the day like everyone else
where tomorrow oh wow yeah okay after
after eight hours I don't know
yes what are you doing I have your boys
I don't how do you employees feel about
all those me but I am a copywriter so I
gotta say they they feel great yeah
they're kind of I'd like to keep those
things really separate but I am a
copywriter and I am a very good writer
I'm still employed by them so that's
that's really good but but I do acting
on the side I'm in the mass report you
know I do little bits and pieces to keep
going but but this yeah just it's
another well we've got you